okay so first of all i have to say this
twitter thread when it first came out i
thought it was hilarious
and then now i'm like they made a film
even more interesting
more fun i just it's blowing my mind for
you guys were you aware of the twitter
thread before getting attached to the
film
thank you um i wasn't i've always i've
been on twitter since 2009 but i
just usually would tweet some random
like positive
and log out i wasn't like a scroller
and yeah this definitely made me a more
active twitter
user yeah riley
yeah i i somebody sent it to me in real
time in
2015 and i definitely read the twitter
thread
where were you sis when you read this i
think i was in my old apartment
on the couch i think i was on the couch
in my apartment
yeah um and yeah i just
you know once you kind of pick it up you
can't put it down she's it's such a
captivating
um wild story story that it goes
you know it's like clear why it went
viral yeah
taylor i know for you you know you're a
trained dancer
you know getting into pole dancing like
was it hard to undo
your ballet yes that's a brilliant
observation
it was actually because i didn't want to
look like a ballerina
look like a stripper baby
but no like you know i just i wanted to
relax into it and
there is something that happens with the
the beautiful the
beauty of being a ballerina or a
technically trained dancer
is also that you become really
self-conscious of like how you place
your body like
definitely like notice how i walk notice
when i'm like
when my posture is bad yeah you know it
can be it's almost like
but then with this you gotta like
unbecome
let all that go yeah you know and get
into the mentality of someone who's
working at a restaurant that's also a
stripper
and that's that's just gonna look
different in someone's body
for sure i know that you guys are
preparing for this role obviously there
are things that you have to take on i
know taylor
you worked at a strip club so i feel
like i just need the t
on this like okay hold on did you did
they know it was you did you have a
disguise where you were just working the
bar did you actually strip were you
backstage did you have a show no no i
script
i did i did it i was did they know it
was you
uh some people were like aren't you the
girl from that dance cheerleader show
and i'm and i'm like
and then they're like what are you doing
here i'm like same thing as you girl
trying to get this
money but uh but no i didn't i didn't
tell
i only told the people that i started to
get close like
i had a partner yeah cinderoni who knew
because she was my friend's friend from
college
yeah and then um this girl savage
who used to watch the show also she was
like okay what's the
why are you here like really what's
going on and then i was like well
i told only a couple of people and i
asked like please just keep it like
low-key like i'm really trying to
just sit into this you know i'm not
trying to like draw attention or
whatever and i looked crazy i looked
like bambi on ice like it wasn't
it wasn't cute at first you know i was a
bit stiff and i was definitely
like holy like i'm in here you know
but it was so liberating like who cares
yeah riley did you do anything in the
strip club um i didn't but i
i had played dancers
twice before so i have taken lessons and
spent
quite a bit of time in strip clubs um
in my day yeah um
and so you know and the other thing is
there was this
mention in the script where
genexa wanted um taylor to be a
phenomenal dancer
and stephanie to be you know average
um and so i kind of
didn't you know i was sort of like oh
well she's supposed to be a little bit
messy and a little bit like
you know she's not you know zola's very
like doing the
very least yeah stephanie's sort of
doing the bare minimum and
getting getting you know the attention
and zola's doing
she's like upside down ordinary job and
and you know
you know yeah there's the idea subtle
racial commentary there
you know yeah no absolutely
um i appreciate you guys time thank you
so much and what a fun movie
thank you for watching good job girls
good job thank you